quand vous aurez tiré Votre Révérence
comment traiter votre dépouille de façon
écologique ce qui a le moins d'impact
c'est de simplement enterrer un corps
sans cercueil ou encore de le composter
selon un procédé précis qu'on appelle
lumusation c'est maintenant légal dans
certains États américains mais ici c'est
interdit si vous êtes hanté par votre
héritage environnemental sachez que
l'aquamation est une option écologique
qui consiste à dissoudre la dépouille
dans une cuve d'eau et de solution
alcaline le liquide est évacué vers
l'usine de traitement des eaux et à la
fin il ne reste que des ossements qui
sont réduits en poudre et déposés dans
une urne l'aquamation pollue moins que
la crémation qui produit des gaz à effet
de serre et que l'inhumation
traditionnelle qui nécessite plusieurs
matériaux et produits chimiques
toutefois elle suscite des réticences
l'Assemblée des évêques du Québec s'est
demandé si ce qu'on fait des résidus
liquides et bien catholiques mais
l'archevêque est prix Nobel Desmond
toutou
à cause de la surprise et choisis
laquamation par conviction
environnementale à l'heure actuelle
laquamation n'est pas disponible partout
elle n'est autorisée que dans quatre
provinces au Québec par exemple on
l'offre seulement à Granby bref mourir
sonne s'improvise pas ça mérite
réflexion avant de dire au revoir passez
le mot
[Musique]